[Music]
of course the super bowl was last
weekend and uh there's one thing that
really surprised me watching it i've
been reading about how popular the
animal planet puppy bowl has become
you've heard of the animal planet puppy
bowl this thing is huge it's an
all-puppy version of the super bowl for
people who don't want to watch the real
thing
there's a yeah there's a moment from it
and uh people seem to every year this
gets more and more popular you love it
it's great well anyway i thought we
should jump on the puppy bandwagon okay
you know if people love it why don't we
get in on this thing
so if you uh don't want to watch the
show we're doing right at this moment we
have an alternative
please enjoy puppy conan
[Applause]
what a great show
[Applause]
there i am
andy what's up
oh
no andy why are you what's wrong with
you andy
i think i think puppy andy hates his wig
as much as i do
and look that's as depressed as i always
am at rehearsal
doesn't it
doesn't it look like puppy conan and
puppy andy are having a fight and we're
yeah yeah we're not talking to each
other we're not talking to each other
right now
oh come on pal
be my friend andy please
you're just shy andy i didn't realize
you were that shy
it's that wig
well let's take this moment right now to
check in with the control room at puppy
conan let's see what's going on
director assistant director everything's
seems to be fine and now it's time for
puppy conan to introduce his special
guest tonight justin bieber this is
exciting let's get justin bieber in
there
[Applause]
hurry
very excited
let's go over there now
this is not worried about puppy yeah no
one's reacting what's wrong with pup and
puppy conan is just taking off now
let's just just let me be here i didn't
realize it was a little
let's just go see puppy conan right here
puppy conan how are you
i love his son we should do our show
[Applause]
[Music]
we should i swear to god we should do hi
guys we should do
we should do a night of our show from
this set
wouldn't that be fantastic
you know what i love anybody tuning in
right now thinks they're having a stroke
yeah
[Applause]
justin
justin bieber's bangs have become a bow
tie
uh all right well we're gonna take how's
puppy andy doing he's fine oh puppy
conan come on up here
hi guy
hi
how are you
look at justin bieber justin bieber
wants in on the action yeah
justin bieber just popped up between my
legs uh
the dog yeah
tmz is gonna run with that quote yeah